تصاعد الجدل حول حفل ترافيس كات في مصر
تكريم منتظر لاحمد عز منافسات سينمائيه
مصريه حاميه في اغسطس والاعلان الترويجي
لنابليون يحبس الانفاس اليكم الابرز في
اسبوع
[موسيقى]
دخل الناشط المصري وائل غنيم على خط الجدل
حول حفل اطلاق الالبوم الجديد لمغني الراب
الامريكي ترافيس كات في منطقه اهرامات
الجيزه كما اعلن المحامي المصري عمرو عبد
السلام عن تقدمه بدعوى قضائيه امام محكمه
القضاء الاداري بمجلس الدوله ضد وزاره
السياحه والاثار لالغاء تصريح الحفل
الغنائي للرابر الامريكي نظرا لما شهدته
حفلاته الغنائيه السابقه بممارسات تخالف
قيم وتقاليد المجتمع المصري بحسب تعبير
عبد السلام كما ذكر المحامي المصري بحادثه
وفاه عشرات الاشخاص اثناء حفله الاخير
بامريكا خلال العام 2021 وكان اسكت قد
اعلن عبر حسابه الرسمي على انستجرام عن
موعد حفله المرتقب لاطلاق البومه الجديد
لتوبيا بمصر في الثامن والعشرين من شهر
تموز يوليو ومنذ ذلك الحين تصاعدت الدعوات
عبر منصات التواصل الاجتماعي في مصر
لالغاء حفل مغني الراب وسط مزاعم مناصرته
لحركه المركزيه الافريقيه وممارسته طقوس
غريبه في حفلاته واغانيه ورغم ذلك تشير
تقارير اعلاميه مصريه بان تذاكر الحفل قد
نفذت
في مصر ايضا حظي خبر الاعلان عن تكريم
احمد عز بجائزه فاتن حمامه للتميز خلال
الدوره المقبله من مهرجان القاهره
السينمائيه الدولي بتفاعل كبير بين محبي
وزملاء الفنان المصري الذي عبر عن سعادته
بهذا التكريم زي ما نقول
يعني دفعه كمان ان انا اقدم للي جاي يبقى
احسن واحسن من اللي فات كمان ان شاء الله
كما اعلن القائمون على مهرجان القاهره
السينمائيه الدولي في وقت سابق عن تكريم
المخرج يسري نصر الله بمنحه جائزه الهرم
الذهبي التقديريه لانجاز العمر خلال
فعاليات دوراته الخامسه والاربعين المقرر
اقامتها في نوفمبر المقبل
وعلى سيره السينما المصريه والتي تشهد
موسما حافلا هذا الصيف يترقب الجمهور
اطلاق العديد من الافلام خلال شهر اب
اغسطس المقبل كفيلم مرعي البريمو لمحمد
هنيدي وابو نسب لمحمد امام وفيلم وش في وش
محمد ممدوح وامينه خليل وخمس جولات لادم
الشرقاوي ونور النبوي وفيلم اولاد حريم
كريم لمصطفى قمر والذي يعتبر الجزء الثاني
من الفيلم الشهير حريم كريم
[موسيقى]
وهناك تسريبات بين فيلم عزيرو من بطوله
محمد رمضان سيكون على قائمه العروض
المتنافسه على ايرادات شباك التذاكر في
مصر والعالم العربي الشهر المقبل ايضا
[تصفيق]
اخيرا والسينمائيا ايضا حقق الاعلان
الرسمي
واخراج ريد سكوت تفاعلا كبيرا على منصات
التواصل عالميا بانتظار موعد عرضه المرتقب
في نوفمبر المقبل